PETE: WELL WE ARE BACK WITH A
LIVE LOOK AT CAPITOL HILL, WHERE
LAWMAKERS AND WHITE HOUSE
OFFICIALS ARE MEETING IN LESS
THAN TWO HOURS.
JILLIAN: SENATE MAJORITY LEADER
MITCH MCCONNELL, MIN LEADER
CHUCK SCHUMER, SPEAKER NANCY
PELOSI AND KEVIN MCCARTHY
WORKING TO HASH OUT DETAILS OF A
$1 TRILLION CORONAVIRUS RELIEF
PACKAGE.
TODD: IT IS EXPECTED TO INCLUDE
FINANCIAL RELIEF FOR AMERICAN
WORKERS AND SMALL BUSINESSES A
FINAL VOTE SCHEDULED FOR
TOMORROW AND WITH THAT WE
BRING IN SOUTH CAROLINA SENATOR
LINDSEY GRAHAM CHAIRMAN OF THE
SENATE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
SENATOR GRANDMAS ALWAYS A
PLEASURE.
HOW CLOSE ARE WE?
>> VERY CLOSE AND IF WE DON’T
DO THIS , YOU SHOULD ALL COME UP
HERE AND KICK US IN THE BUTT.
TODD: [LAUGHTER]
>> WE’RE GOING TO PASS THE BILL
MONDAY.
IT’S GOING TO HELP PEOPLE WHO
HAVE LOST THEIR PAYCHECKS TO GET
INCOME.
IT’S GOING TO HELP HOSPITALS WHO
HAVE BEEN OVERRUN, WITH MONEY TO
GET THROUGH THIS , AND IT’S
GOING TO HELP INCREASE MEDICAL
SUPPLIES AND STABILIZE THE
ECONOMY.
WE’RE FIGHTING A TWO-FRONT WAR.
ONE IS THE VIRUS ITSELF.
THE OTHER IS THE ECONOMY THAT’S
BEEN LOCKED DOWN BECAUSE OF
CONTAINMENT POLICIES.
PETE: IN YOUR MIND, SENATOR AS
YOU LOOK AT THIS BILL WHICH
WAR IS MORE IMPORTANT, NOT THAT
YOU NECESSARILY HAVE TO CHOOSE
BETWEEN THE TWO.
>> YOU DO.
PETE: YOU KIND OF DO SO
ULTIMATELY $2 TRILLION BILL IF
YOU GO ALL IN ON THE WAR TO
PREVENT EVERYONE FROM GETTING
SICK AND SHUT THE ECONOMY DOWN
FOR TWO MONTHS WHERE ARE YOU ON
THAT BALANCE?
>> THE VIRUS IS GERMANY AND THE
ECONOMY IS JAPAN.
SO WE’RE BUYING TIME IN THIS
BILL.
WE’RE PAYING FOR CONTAINMENT,
WE’RE TRYING TO LOWER THE
INFECTION RATE, AND HERE IS
WHAT I BELIEVE IF WE DID NOTHING
OVER 2 MILLION AMERICANS WOULD
DIE FROM THE VIRUS, HALF THE
POPULATION BE INFECTED, AND
YOU’D HAVE A MORTALITY RATE
AROUND 1% PLUS, AND IF YOU ACT
DECISIVELY AND HAVE AGGRESSIVE
CONTAINMENT POLICIES, WE STOP
THE INFECTION FROM SPREADING
UNTIL WE CAN GET THERAPIES AND
VACCINES TO KILL THIS DAMN THING
SO MY NUMBER ONE GOAL IS TO GO
ALL IN ON THE HEALTHCARE FRONT
TO FIND THERAPIES AND VACCINES
SOONER RATHER THAN LATER TO KILL
THE VIRUS, AND LESSENS ITS
EFFECT ON PEOPLE AND THE ECONOMY
LOCKDOWN IS TO BUY TIME TO
ACCOMPLISH THAT.
JILLIAN: YOU KNOW, SENATOR SO
MANY PEOPLE WANT SO MANY ANSWERS
TO THIS , YOU TALK ABOUT FINDING
A VACCINE AND YOU TALK ABOUT
GETTING PEOPLE THE MONEY THEY
REALLY NEED RIG NOW.
FOR THOSE PEOPLE AT HOME WHO ARE
IN NEED OF HELP SITTING HERE
WATCHING CAN YOU GIVE US A
GLIMPSE OF BEHIND THE SCENES
WHAT EXACTLY IS GOING ON TO TRY
AND MAKE THAT HAPPEN?
>> WELL NUMBER ONE, WE ALL
AGREE UP HERE THAT A SMALL
BUSINESS, THERE’S 1,700
RESTAURANTS IN MYRTLE BEACH, ALL
OF THEM ARE SHUTDOWN BECAUSE OF
THE CONTAINMENT POLICIES.
WE’LL ASK THE BUSINESS OWNERS TO
GO TO THE BANK AND GET A LOAN
AND PAY THEIR EMPLOYEES UP TO
80,000 IN SALARY, PAY THE
MORTGAGE, PAY THE RENT
PAYMENT AND WE’LL FORGIVE SIX
WEEKS OF IT AND HOPEFULLY GET
THIS BEHIND US.
WE’RE GOING TO INCREASE
DRAMATICALLY UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE AVAILABLE TO PEOPLE,
THE MOST YOU COULD GET IN SOUTH
CAROLINA IS $326 A WEEK.
WE’RE GOING TO DRAMATICALLY
INCREASE THAT BECAUSE THAT’S NOT
ENOUGH TO LIVE ON, AND MAJOR
COMPANIES WHO ARE OTHERWISE
HEALTHY HAVE NO BUSINESS, WE’RE
GOING TO FLOAT THEM LOANS UNTIL
THEY GET THROUGH THIS.
WE’RE GOING TO RELIEVE STUDENT
DEBT BURDEN BY SAYING YOU DON’T
HAVE TO PAY YOUR STUDENT LOAN
FOR SIX MONTHS, WE’RE GOING TO
TAKE BURDENS OFF PEOPLE, GET
THEIR PAYCHECK STABILIZED
AND AS TO THE VIRUS, WE’RE GOING
TO GIVE A LOT OF MONEY TO
HOSPITALS SO THEY DON’T GET
OVERWHELMED.
TODD: SENATOR LET’S JUMP INTO
ONE OF THE THINGS YOU SAID WE’RE
NOT TALKING ABOUT THE MYRTLE
BEACH ESTABLISHMENTS OR  HAVING
ANY GOVERNMENT INTERVENTION,
ASIDE FROM THE MONEY THEY ARE
GOING TO GET BUT YOU DID MENTION
THE BIG CORPORATIONS AND YOU
MENTIONED LOANS TO THOSE.
EARLIER ON THE SHOW WE HAD YOUR
COLLEAGUE SENATOR SCOTT FROM
FLORIDA ON AND WHEN I ASKED HIM
SHOULD GOVERNMENT, NON-VOTING
BUT FINANCIALLY, GET SOME SORT
OF STOCK IN THESE COMPANIES
BECAUSE OF THE MONEY THAT
THEY’RE GIVING YOU AND AGAIN I’M
FOCUSING ON THE BIG COMPANIES
AND HE SAID YES THE GOVERNMENT
SHOULD MAKE SOME MONEY OFF OF
THE INVESTMENT THEY ARE PUTTING
IN THESE COMPANIES TO HELP PAY
FOR THIS ON THE BACK END.
DO YOU AGREE?
>> WELL I THINK IT SHOULD BE
LOANS NOT GRANTS.
I DON’T PRETEND TO KNOW HOW TO
MAKE MONEY OFF ALL OF THIS BUT I
JUST DON’T WANT COMPANIES TO GET
GRANTS, LIKE BOEING.
THE 787, WHICH IS THE PREMIER
WIDE BODIED JET IN THE WORLD IS
MADE IN CHARLESTON, SOUTH
CAROLINA.
THE 737 MAX HAS BEEN A DISASTER.
I DON’T WANT TO BAIL OUT BOEING
BECAUSE OF THE 737 PROBLEM, BUT
IF WE DON’T HELP BOEING KEEP THE
787 PRODUCTION LINE IN BEING
, WE’RE GOING TO GIVE THE
ENTIRE WORLD MARKET TO
AIRBUS.
I PROMISE YOU, THE EUROPEANS ARE
NOT GOING TO LET AIRBUS FAIL, SO
WHAT I’M TRYING TO DO IS MAKE
SURE THAT BIG CORPORATIONS GET
LOANS, NOT GRANTS, SO THEY
CAN GET THROUGH THIS.
I’M TRYING TO MAKE SURE
INDIVIDUALS WHOSE LOST THEIR
PAYCHECK, THEY GET AN INCOME
STREAM BEGINNING THIS WEEK.
JILLIAN: SENATOR MOST AMERICANS
RIGHT NOW ARE WORRIED ABOUT
THEIR INCOME, THEIR JOBS, AND
THERE ARE PREDICTIONS RIGHT NOW
SHOWING THAT THIS CORONAVIRUS
COULD TRIGGER A DOWNTURN COSTING
UP TO 5 MILLION U.S. JOBS.
WHERE DO WE GO FROM THERE?
>> WELL I DON’T EVEN BELIEVE
THE 5 MILLION.
I BELIEVE 70% OF THE ECONOMY IS
SHUTDOWN SIMPLY BECAUSE YOU
CAN’T BE AROUND 10 PEOPLE.
AS LONG AS WE HAVE A CONTAINMENT
POLICY THAT YOU SHOULD HUNKER
DOWN IN PLACE IN
CALIFORNIA AND NEW YORK, IMAGINE
HOW THAT EFFECTS THE ECONOMY.
YOU’VE GOT THE TWO LARGEST
STATES IN THE UNION BASICALLY
SHUT DOWN.
THAT EFFECTS ALL OF US, AS LONG